the really cool thing about Dentistry
it's not a fad things aren't going to
change everyone has teeth everyone has
teeth and if you don't have teeth you're
still a customer Dentures or something
and so in that world we have the luxury
of being able to project out with some
degree of confidence I would say the
future
I want dentists over the next few years
to say things like how could I ever live
without Dandy
there's a ton more responsibilities and
obligations you have as a dental
practice owner and operator
Beyond actually helping people get
better all sorts of administrative
burdens and overheads that don't
actually help you deliver care to
patients but are nonetheless required to
keep your practice afloat and our vision
is we want to create a situation where
as a practitioner as a dentist you can
help people get better without having to
think about and spend half or more than
half your time on all these different
auxiliary responsibilities and so we've
started along that Journey along a
vision by building the world's first All
Digital dental lab helping people get
crowns Bridges veneers night guards and
clear liners through an inclusively
digital workflow and making that part of
running their dental practice as easy as
possible
growing up I really wanted to become a
professional tennis player I became
pretty good but very quickly realized I
wasn't going to become the next Roger
Federer and so somehow got into the
world of technology and realized that it
had incredible power to make things 10
better and so with that was just
interested in solving problems and
trying to create value for other folks
I have a long history of dental problems
I've been sort of working and thinking
about how to help dentists for a while
we went to college together and we
actually met in a business ethics class
to be honest Dan was an [ __ ] yeah I
was he was he was that guy
I was the most obnoxious let's just say
obnoxious how about that that's fair
it's okay he was just the he was this
person raising his hand and asking all
the the questions to the professor and
you know I think I guess I thought to
myself
huh probably so maybe I should start
where I should learn more about them and
that's pretty much it said and we've
been best friends ever since
I think the aha moment for us was two
two and a half years ago Tony and I uh
linked up on a specific problem in
dentistry that we both were really
passionate about we both realized
there's a real missing piece in the way
dental offices were operating that was
honestly creating a lot of hardship and
pain for dentists and their patients we
we both I think saw that at the same
time that I think really inspired us to
like truly link up together for the long
run and actually really build Danny
together
we serve thousands of dentists in the
U.S and soon will serve you know
dentists globally which is incredibly
exciting hundreds of employees today
which is a far cry from where we were as
you know the two of us you know just a
few years ago so it's been a pretty as
you can imagine a pretty incredible
journey over the last you know the less
than three years
we got this real you know in my opinion
once in a lifetime opportunity to really
build something unique and special for
honestly a group of people that don't
get as much attention from technology
companies that I think they should
just wanna
not waste that opportunity
I think what I'm realizing is when you
first start the company it feels like it
is kind of a long ways off
what what is getting cool about where
we're at today is that version of the
future is actually so much closer than
it was two and a half years ago that's a
future that it motivates ourselves when
there's our teams and now it's like I
think we're much more compelled by what
we could build what the experience could
look like for both dentists their
patients overall
foreign